[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends would you like
to hear an amazing fact on September 4
2019 a 73 year old woman in southern
India the state of andhra pradesh gave
birth to twin girls
mrs. Yara mati said that she and her
husband who is 82 years old have been
married for some 57 years and have
always wanted children but they've been
unable to conceive until now she adds
that she felt stigmatized in her
community in her village and they'd
often exclude her from social gatherings
because she was not a mother they would
call me a childless lady she said the
elderly couple first approached a
fertility clinic about having children
last year and then after some
encouraging test results the doctors
agreed to perform one round of in vitro
fertilization and then as they say in
French voila
the twin girls each weighing about two
and a half pounds were delivered by
cesarean section which is typical for a
high-risk pregnancy both babies are
doing fine
and he says Yara mati said this is the
happiest time of my life
you know the Bible says this is not the
first time that an elderly mother gave
birth stay with his friends we're going
to learn more on this edition of Bible
answers why you're listening to Bible
answers live honest answers to your
Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 years now
around the country and we just love
talking about the Word of God and I know
we have some friends that are not only
listening on a variety of stations and
satellite radio but they may be watching
on our Facebook page this program you
can see it for what it's worth you can
see it's streaming at the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page or at the amazing facts
Facebook page and as we always do we're
going to begin the program with a word
of Prayer
loving Lord again we always come before
you knowing that these words are spirit
and they are life and spiritual things
are spiritually discerned so we pray for
the Holy Ghost to give us understanding
as we open this blessed book and we just
thank you Lord we pray that Jesus will
be in our midst wherever we are and we
ask this in Christ's name Amen well I
tell you friends that caught my
attention when I heard the news report
about a 73 year old woman that gave
birth now that's phenomenal right there
but two twins no less and the husband is
82 he no I had to actually question the
fertility clinic that would accept a
person coming a couple that age and
saying we want to have a baby
you know some of those folks in India
live a long time and let's hope that she
can get them through college but I've
actually been to Andhra Pradesh they're
in southern India and it is so important
for them that they have children and
they have a family something like it was
in Bible times
and as I mentioned there's a couple of
stories of miracle births in the Bible
Elizabeth of course and you can read in
Luke chapter one this is the mother of
John the Baptist Zechariah and Elizabeth
and it says they were both well advanced
in years it doesn't tell us her age but
it seemed like she was way past what
you'd expect having children they've
kind of given up on the possibility and
then they had John the Baptist and of
course you read about Sarah it tells us
she was 90 now 90 back then was not
quite like 90 today because Abraham
lived 175 so they had a longer life
expectancy but 90 was still way beyond
what you'd expect a person to have
children matter of fact it tells us in
the Bible that Sarah had already gone
through menopause so that was a miracle
and then of course you've got the
miracle of Jesus birth and you read in
Matthew 1:18 now the birth of Jesus was
as follows his mother was betrothed to
Joseph but before they came together she
was found to be with child of the Holy
Spirit and then you read a few verses
later says behold the angel of the Lord
appeared to Joseph in a dream saying
Joseph do not be afraid to take Mary to
his wife for that which is conceived in
her is of the Holy Spirit you know what
happened to Mary a woman in the Bible
analogy is something like a church and
and here you've got this woman who has
this miracle miracle new birth and then
Jesus tells us that unless we experience
the new birth we cannot be transformed
into his image so it's sort of a symbol
I mean it really did happen but what
happened there is also an analogy of
what needs to happen in us we must be
born again there needs to be a miracle
birth of God's Spirit in our hearts
where Christ live is within it's like
that song they sing little town of
Bethlehem verses be born in us today or
have you experienced new birth friends
God wants you to and we have an offer
that I think will be a blessing to you
it's free we'll send you the book Holy
Spirit the need Holy Spirit the need
written by yours truly
if you like a copy of that simply call
or read
doors line which is 808 three five six
seven four seven and that's different
from the phone line to calling your
question to get your resource it's 808
three five six seven four seven ask for
the book on the Holy Spirit will be
offering other resources through the
night so you might want to keep that
number or your PIN handy you can also
read that at the amazing facts website
under our free resources
that's simply amazing facts dot o-r-g
once again to call in with your
questions eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven calling now good
chance getting your question on the
program we're gonna go to the phones
we're gonna be talking to Holly who's
calling from Alabama Holly you're on the
air with Bible answers live hey brother
we are here with a large radio in
Birmingham glad to talk to you again we
have a quick question we just wanted to
follow up on a challenge that one of our
speakers gave us one day he said if you
only have thirty Seconds to a minute
in the business world is an elevator
speech to give the kind of the last
message the gospel the more than just
the gospel but really like an endtime
present truth kind of gospel how would
you give that in 30 seconds to a minute
well first of all hi that it is
difficult of course to make a complete
gospel presentation but we should never
underestimate what the Holy Spirit can
do I heard one time Charles Spurgeon
came into an auditorium and this is
before they had PA systems and nobody
was there and he thought I'm gonna test
the acoustics and so he walked to the
podium and he said John 3:16 you know
God so loved the world and he listened
to it and he thought oh that's good yep
and then he walked out well a few days
later when he was doing the series there
a man came up and he said I want to
thank you for for bringing me to the
Lord and he said I just want to let you
know I was the custodian and I was
cleaning in the back when you came to
test the acoustics and all I heard was
that verse that you said and I gave him
a heart to the Lord right then so one
verse did it that was less than 60
seconds I would say one of the most
important things you can do is you share
your testimony Holly yeah you have to
reduce it but you can just say you know
my life was a mess I was so lost I had
no peace and I found a Bible I read the
Bible and I brought Jesus into my Jesus
came into my life and he's transformed
me now right there you telling him where
you were where you've come from and what
did it the Word of God so they can go
and say well I want to look at the Bible
and find out more the others a variety
of ways to talk to a person I think you
have to be careful about saying there's
one set speech because my experience has
told me everybody I talked to is at a
different place in their life and you
might need to say something different to
them and I'm always surprised after I
preach from week to week someone will
come up to me and say that's exactly
what I needed to hear no I had no never
would have dreamed that's what they
needed to hear but God knew so the Lord
has to guide you from case to case when
you have those brief encounters and you
want to say something for the Lord and
keep in mind you know what's helped me
is I've sometimes thought you know how
do I bring this person to the Lord I've
got you know I pick up a hitchhiker I
know I'm gonna just take him five miles
I've only got you know 10 minutes or
whatever what can I say and the Lord
reminded me you not may not do all the
the sowing the harvesting and reaping in
10 minutes maybe your job right now is
to sow the seed someone else is going to
cultivate the seed it's gonna grow when
someone else will come along later and
harvest so nobody needs to feel like
we've got to do the whole thing at once
but there are times happened to Karen
and I this week we went to visit a
friend in the hospital in ICU prayed
with him I actually was going to come
and see him today but I thought I better
see him before I leave town went to the
hospital visited him in ICU prayed with
him so thankful we did and he passed
away that night and you never know when
a person is gonna be hearing a prayer or
the Word of God for the last time
happened to me this week so he always
want to pray God will lead you hey Thank
You Holly I hope
that helps answer your question and
we're gonna talk next with Chris who is
calling from Florida Chris you're on the
air with Bible answers live yes thank
you first I just have a question about
again about what happens to the believer
when he dies and there I referred so
first a felonious forceful team okay and
you sure you well in first Thessalonians
it says of course that the Lord descends
from heaven with a shout the voice of
the Archangel the Trump of God then we
who are alive and remain are caught up
to meet them in the clouds you you know
it's pretty clear that we're sleeping it
says we don't need to sorrow as others
that have no hope so the dead are
sleeping until the resurrection
let me read verse 14 for if we believe
that Jesus died and rose again even so
God will bring with him those who sleep
so you're thinking that they're already
alive and God brings them with him
correct that the believers that died in
Christ they are alive and then with God
they saw a spirit if you will well that
did let me tell you why I think you're
getting that idea when he says first of
all keep in mind in verse 13 he sets the
stage I'm in first Thessalonians 4:13 I
do not want you to be ignorant brethren
concerning those who have fallen asleep
he's talking about the dead so you don't
sorrow as others that have no hope for
if we believe that Jesus died and rose
again the Christ didn't rise again until
he rose again he was a dead in the grave
until he rose even so God will bring
with him those who sleep in Jesus now he
gives the sequence for we say to you by
the word of the Lord that we who are
alive and remain until the coming of the
Lord will by no means precede that means
go before those who are asleep now it
tells us when they rise for the Lord
will descend from heaven with a shout
with the voice of the Archangel the
Trump of God the dead in Christ will
rise first he's saying they rise to meet
the Lord in the air first before us then
we who are alive and remain are caught
up to meet them so when we get to the
Lord they're with him that's why he says
in verse 14 they're with him
because they've risen first but how can
Jesus bring those that died in him at
the resurrection if they are not with
him so do you think that when someone
dies their conscious no I believe that
there is distinction between the body
and the soul knowing yeah I don't mean
that they're alive I mean but when
someone dies in the Lord
do you believe they're floating around
in their conscious of what's happening
no yeah they're asleep the Bible says
the living know they'll die but the dead
don't know anything and it says until
the resurrection jesus said they'll be
raised in the last day John chapter 6 so
the dead asleep I'm sorry go ahead
I believe that the body dies not the
body dies not the spirit soul if you
will
goes in it in case of believer it's in
presence of God do you believe it's a
lot do you believe it's conscious
because it is you read in Ecclesiastes 9
it says the living know they all died
and the dead don't know anything and
again it says in Psalms that that the
dead do not praise the Lord you know if
the soul of the deceased are praising
God to be absent from the body is to be
present where the Lord means as soon as
you die there's no consciousness of time
your next awareness your next
consciousness is the resurrection at the
Second Coming so for you it seems
immediate it's the twinkling of an eye
but Christ that the resurrection and the
judgment are not till the last day so
the idea that disembodied souls are
floating around and they're aware and
Bible says they're asleep Jesus
performed 12 resurrections in the Bible
well not Jesus but they're about 12
resurrections in the Bible some by
Christ in all of those resurrections
none of them ever commented on any
awareness during death we do have a
study guide you may have already seen it
Chris it says are the dead really dead I
hope that may help a little bit talking
next with Anthony in Rochester New York
Anthony you're on the air with Bible
answers live hi
bachelor how are you good thanks for
calling in your question and my question
is I was wondering if you could put a
basic order of events of Jesus betrayal
and the Garden of Gethsemane because I
look in Lou who can I see it says that
Judas came up immediately when they came
with the soldiers and he came and kissed
them just Christ and then I see him like
Javan the soldiers come and they say hey
where's there's Jesus and he says or
they asked him are you Jesus and he says
I am and they fall backwards or
something like that so I just wonder
between four Gospels like what is the
order of offense of when they came to
arrest Jesus yeah it's a good question
you'll see yeah and of course this to me
is proof that the Bible is true is
because you're getting independent
reports from John in Matthew and Mark
about what happened and Luke at that
event you know I believe that Judas did
first of all it's dark secondly there
was nothing really outstanding about the
look of Jesus because Jesus always kind
of slipped through the crowd he looked
like yeah another Galilean or a Nazarene
so they said to Judas they said you know
you're gonna know which one he is just
so we don't arrest the wrong one go up
and you help identify him and Judas came
up and kissed him and said hail master
and he said you betraying the Son of man
with a kiss and his Jesus stepped away
Jesus asked them who are you seeking
they said no we're seeking Jesus he said
I am he and they fell back but I think
that's after Judas had already kissed
him now that's been my understanding you
know you kind of have to piece it
together but there was there a specific
part that you felt there might be a
conflict yeah it was mainly just that
part I wasn't sure if you know which one
came before the other or which sir
because it came before the other and
then also the whole situation yeah yeah
name Anthony you're cuttin out on us I'm
sorry
you start your phones you might be too
far away from the cell tower it's kind
of going in and out yeah the events when
you line up the events around the cross
there are some Bibles that have a
parallel gospel and they they actually
put those things in chronological order
and you might find one of those I'm
pretty sure you will online and of
course those are the opinions of
commentators but it does help it
it does help your understanding of how
it can all fit anyway thank you for your
question anthony hope that helps a
little bit
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767 't but it's not something
intangible
you can see right through it so that's
the only thing I've come up with I
couldn't be wrong but that's a good
question
he says everything else is good the last
day he says it's very good yeah well
apart from the symbolic you know of
creation being symbolic of salvation I
sort of thought that maybe the God
looked into the future maybe saw what
would happen
what he did on the second day you know
the where the waters of the flood came
from and he knew that that was going to
happen and sort of in his sworn
knowledge just it was he it was
necessary but it wasn't good
oh I searched he's saying I've never
thought of that before that's
interesting yeah I'm not sure that
someone else I think may have suggested
that because Satan was sometimes called
the Prince of the power of the air and
in the second day he made air atmosphere
and I thought well maybe that's why he
didn't say it was good it was a kind of
a domain that was associated at one
point with the devil I don't know but
it's a good question and thank you I
hope that helps a little we're gonna be
talking next with the is it Emil calling
from Massachusetts Emil is that right
yeah yes but even evening thank you for
calling thank you pastor doc for your
ministry and I really want to first
thank you for the person that came from
your ministry to visit with us like a
week ago
so wonderful yes we were very surprised
that somebody took their time to come
and visit us
well praise alert so thank you very much
yeah my question tonight is related to
somehow what you started the program
with I heard the Minister for preaching
about how we are not going not get to
heaven not married so we're gonna have
to be married when we get to heaven and
now I know that Jesus said it's not
going to be married to happen but how
are we going to be related to our wives
or spouses when we're going to get to
heaven that's a good question
you know Jesus did say in heaven they
neither marry nor are they given in
marriage now that the word marry is and
actually it's a verb it's an action and
that seems to imply there are no new
marriages keep in mind God told Adam and
Eve be fruitful
multiply and fill the earth so at some
point the earth would be filled
theoretically God probably did not plan
for humans to procreate indefinitely or
you know just be swimming in people
there'd be no world left just because of
the way you know exponential growth
works so he said to go in to fill or
inhabit the earth subdue the earth and
once they filled and populated the earth
there probably wouldn't you know
everyone's gonna be happy in heaven God
would not make us with any need that
could not be satisfied now does that
make sense
God will not create us in heaven even
with our new bodies with a need that
would not be satisfied so for those in
this world that are married and I'm not
talking about David or Solomon that had
me in are dozens of wives or Solomon had
hundreds of wives but will God give Adam
and Eve divorce papers when they get to
heaven all right probably not yeah so
those who so there may not be any new
marriages but for those who already are
married and they're best friends in the
kingdom God's not gonna tell them they
can't live together that's my opinion
and at least temporarily there will be
children in heaven because Bible talks
about children playing you know children
will be resurrected as children then I
can be resurrected as adults or if
there's children alive when Christ comes
you read in Malachi chapter 4 they'll go
forth and grow up so there's some
growing that children do it says in
Zechariah the children will be playing
in the streets safely so for a while
anyway there's gonna be some children in
the new earth hey thank you we're gonna
try and squeeze in another call a meal
before our break and we're talking to
Becky and Grand Ledge Michigan Becky
you're on the air with Bible answers
live pastor Doug hi my mom passed away
last night hmm
and I need prayer many encouragement I
am so sorry to hear that would it be
okay if I just have a prayer with you
right now Becky yeah well first of all
before I pray with you let me give you a
little encouragement who was your mother
a believer yeah then you know the Bible
says that it's not forever it's just a
very separation if you are trusting in
the Lord and she died trusting in the
Lord
her next conscious thought is the
resurrection and you will be reunited
and so you just pray that in the
meantime you can be a faithful witness
and servant of the Lord just look
forward to that day Paul refers to the
Lord's coming as the Blessed hope and
when we will be reunited with the ones
we love and so let me just have a prayer
for you right now Becky father in heaven
I want to thank you for your your
promises in your word that though death
is an enemy that when Jesus comes death
will be destroyed there'll be no more
sting no more victory to death and even
death and the grave will be cast into
the lake of fire and there'll be no more
pain or suffering in the new world
I pray be with Becky and just help her
to find comfort the way that you
comforted there at the tomb of Lazarus
because you brought him back help Becky
know that she can see her mother again
and others who are grieving with her I
thank you and pray in Jesus name Amen
all right well thank you for your call
Becky you know I'm looking at the phone
and I'm looking at the clock now we are
gonna be taking a bunch more phone calls
so don't go away friends but it's
probably not fair in the next 56 seconds
to try to start another call I like to
start relaxed so I can think about the
question give you a fair chance to
articulate the question and do my best
to answer it just in case you're
wondering we don't ever want to cut
anyone off but we do try to budget the
questions to about three four minutes
per person and to give as many people a
chance as they can I also want to remind
you that amazing facts has noodles and
gobs a blizzard a kaleidoscope of
information at our website you start
clicking it'll just go on and on with
videos Bible questions booklets articles
sermons other websites that have great
material and so it's just a great
one-stop shopping place for truth and
that's the amazing facts website very
simple amazing facts not a large e gonna
come back for more questions stay with
us
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com if you enjoy hearing solid
biblical answers on Bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore com or by calling 1-800
538 7275 for life changing Christian
resources this @af bookstore com find
out what the critics are raving about
top scholars and theologians from around
the country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore com
[Music]
every Bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 spoke and/or
amazing facts you may notice a
difference in the background that's
because we've just moved into our new
office building we're so thankful that
we've been working on getting in some
new facilities for several years and we
are in now studio is not completely
completely set up will end up
broadcasting this program with three or
four cameras and a little set so we may
even bring in some guests when we get
into the new studio but we're in a kind
of a transition it's we're in limbo you
might say right now but we're going to
go back to the phones and talking next
with Lester who's calling from Texas
Lester you're on the air where the Bible
answers live hey pastor Doug how are you
good thanks for calling
thanks my question is just regarding how
do we deal with family members or
friends that no longer have a desire to
have a relationship with Christ and just
keeping in mind like part of it we don't
want to just force anything on anyone
but at the same time we have that urge
of responsibility to actually be the
hands and feet of Christ yeah you will
you need tact diplomacy grace wisdom you
also need to you know evaluate you
you've got some friends and family
family you're specifically asking about
that are open they may not be believing
but they're open to talk about it and
you know if the opportunity presents
itself share with them then you've got
family and sometimes parents have to do
this with their kids they become adults
and they say you know I don't know if I
want to be Christian now and they're out
in the world
don't preach at them you can drive them
away where they don't want to hear
anything you've got to pray and pray
that God watches over them and he works
in their hearts through the spirit and
as opportunity presents itself you
always represent Christ
now with anybody there's really three
things you can do to reach them whether
they're family friends enemy those three
things are share information if they're
open to listen be a good witness and
then pray for them those are the three
things they're powerful but there's only
three things let your light shine be a
good example if they'll discuss and you
want to talk about give them a Bible
study a book a video a link whatever it
is so you share information and then
third thing is you pray for them and
that goes a long way in trying to touch
and reach the people that we care about
so does that help a little bit Lester
yeah no that that definitely helps thank
you all right hey thanks so much we
appreciate your call and we're gonna go
talk to Mickey in Michigan Mickey you're
on the air with Bible answers live
hey good do you mean evening thank you
for taking the call yeah I was listening
to you speak to that gentleman about the
dead and whether or not when we die do
we go to heaven
and I thought about what Jesus said he
said he's he's the God of Abraham Isaac
and Jacob now he said I'm the god of the
living not to dead and it almost said
you know it sounds like he's saying
there with him currently in heaven well
when a person is asleep they're not dead
now there are we got to be careful
because there are some exceptions there
are some people who are obviously with
Christ Moses appeared to Jesus you can
read in the book of Jude that Moses was
specially resurrected Elijah appeared to
Jesus and this is Mark chapter 9 Moses
and Elijah appeared to him Elijah went
to heaven in a fiery chariot the average
person when they die the Bible says
they're asleep let me give you an
example if you look in Acts chapter 2
keep in mind acts 2 is after the death
and resurrection of Christ Peter says in
Acts chapter 2 David his tomb is with us
to this day he is dead buried and not
ascended to heaven well it's pretty
clear David his daddy's bury is not in
heaven and David is going to be in the
resurrection for David when he died
about a thousand years BC his next
conscious thought will be opening his
eyes with a glorified body but it's
gonna seem like three seconds for him
not three thousand years the dead are
sleeping a dreamless unconscious sleep
until the resurrection Bible says okay
go ahead I'm sorry no no I was going to
say that the scripture as well that you
know Paul Paul said to be absent from
the body is to be present with the Lord
so yeah I will respectfully disagree
with you on this one but I appreciate
you taking my call sir well I do I
actually agree with that verse because
if you die your next conscious thought
is the resurrection and the presence of
God you know there's no time now but
Jesus said when he came to the tomb of
Lazarus Martha said well I know he'll
rise in the resurrection on the last day
the dead are asleep and then it tells us
in Ecclesiastes as I mentioned earlier
the dead don't know anything and Bible
says in Psalm 146 put not
trust in Princes neither in the son of
man in whom there is no help when he
dies his breath goes forth his thoughts
perish you don't think anything until
the resurrection and you get your
glorified body the reason this is
important for Christians to understand
is Saul tried to communicate with the
dead and he died the next day
hi he was told not to consult the dead
and people who think that the dead are
floating around or their spirits are
floating around and that you can
communicate with him Bible says that
that's a sin it's called consulting a
medium Isaiah said you know don't be
trying to consult the dead how they're
asleep Jesus said my friend Lazarus is
asleep and I'm going to wake him that's
John chapter 11 you know anyone who has
a question about that I do hope you'll
look for the study guide it's free and
it's called are the dead really dead and
I think once a person reads that may see
all the verses it starts to make sense
people are worried they think well my
loved one died and you're telling me
they're just in the ground no they're
not aware of being in the ground their
next conscious thought is the presence
of the Lord but the resurrection hasn't
happened yet we live in time God lives
outside of time they're not in heaven
God is not there not in Hades burning
the judgment hasn't happened the
resurrection they're both future please
order the study guide are the dead
really dead read it for free just go to
the amazing facts website that's amazing
in fact so rgp the study guide if you'd
like it is 800 463 I'm sorry 800 eight
three five six seven four seven if you
want that free study guide 800 eight
three five six seven four seven amazing
facts offer some of the best Christian
resources for all ages we help our
products will enrich your life and your
walk with the Lord
dad the subject everyone thinks about
but no one enjoys talking about is there
life after death the afterlife mystery
is a brand new sharing magazine that
answers all your questions get yours
today by calling 855-578-6767 tin the
churches for they are not permitted to
speak but they're to be submissive as
the law says and if they want to learn
something let them ask their own
husbands at home for it's shameful for
women to speak in the church now when
Paul refers to as a law says he's
talking about a woman submitting to her
husband when God said to to Eve he said
I'm gonna multiply your sorrow and your
conception and pain you'll bring forth
children your desire will be for your
husband and he will rule over you what
that means is that between the man and
the woman that God was really saying
that the man is to be the servant leader
in the family just the Bible says
husband's love your wives as Christ
loved as a church it says that the head
of Christ a head of man is Christ and
the head of woman is man and so men were
designed to be the protectors providers
leaders in the family now in this first
year in 1st Corinthians I don't think
that Paul is making a unilateral
statement that a woman can never speak
in a church you read all of first
Corinthians and they had some very
unique problems where the church
services were very disruptive
he talks a lot about people speaking in
different tongues that people didn't
understand he said you need to wait
until there's a translator and evidently
some of the women were teaching and
correcting their husbands in front of
others in interrupting the service keep
in mind that in this culture the women
and men often did not sit together
I go to church in India frequently and
the men and women don't sit together in
most of the churches they sit separately
because the ideas they want their minds
to be pure you see that in in some
Muslim countries back in Bible times the
men and women did not sit together they
did not in the Hebrew synagogues and
chances are the early churches they did
not so women were calling across the the
barrier or calling across the courtyard
or whatever the meeting was talking to
their husbands correcting their husbands
teaching their husbands and and Paul
said this is embarrassing your husbands
don't interrupt be submissive ask them
when you get home they're not seeing a
woman's never to speak in church because
you have cases where you have women who
are prophetess and you have the
daughters of Philip that did prophesy
you've got a henna who was in the temple
you have Anna in the New Testament who
spoke in the temple when Jesus was
dedicated so you know I have a book a
manual I'll send you a free copy if
you'd like it and it's called women in
ministry and it addresses these verses
anybody if you want to understand this
better I'd recommend you ask for the
free book women in ministry and call the
resource line that's 883 560 747 883
five six seven four seven and asked for
the book of women in ministry thank you
for your call Emanuel gonna talk next to
Yvonne in North Carolina
Yvonne you're on the air with Bible
answers live oh hi I was calling because
I'm currently reading through first
Chronicles and in the chronology in
first chronicles 6 verse 39 and in verse
44 I was it kind of caught my eye
because in verse 39
first Chronicle 6 it mentions the right
hand and then in verse 44 it mentions
the left hand so it kind of threw me off
a little bit so I was kind of curious
about that alright well we're gonna
we're going to look at this together
because I don't know that I've ever had
that question before let me read it and
his brother Asaph who stood at his right
hand was Asaph the son of Barak I had
the son of shamea and then you said in
verse what was the other one 40 okay
and they're Brethren's the sons of Mary
I on the left hand where Ethan the son
of Keisha and AB died the son of Moloch
oh you know what here he's talking in in
this is talking about I believe the
musicians in the house of the Lord and
where they were stationed they actually
had them on the right and the left I
think in the temple and so he's
basically saying you know where these
different choir leaders were I think
that they were from the house of Levi or
Aaron where they were stationed in the
temple as they sang their singers yeah
this is from the family of Levi which
was Moses family and Aaron how can like
a common person like me gain a spiritual
blessing from reading from reading like
this chapter for instance how would I
know that well you know what the Bible
is like a mine and sometimes you've got
some nuggets that are laying on the
surface and then you've got some that
are underground you dig a little bit and
then sometimes you got a tunnel for and
you might find gold and diamonds but
they're harder to get and it may take a
little longer when I first started
reading the Bible this I couldn't even
say these names just went totally over
my head but the Bible just it's got
treasure as you go deeper let me give
you an example when you get to
revelation and it talks about the
hundred and forty-four thousand well you
know then you read chronicles you say
wow look at that
David divided the the army and he
divided the priests into two hundred and
eighty eight which is twice a hundred
and forty-four and you start saying oh
so when you get to the New Testament it
talks about the 12 apostles and 144,000
they're all derivatives of 12 and
start seeing the perfect numbers that
are here and the other thing is each one
of these names you can get yourself a
dictionary of Bible names there's a
meaning and when you go through the
meaning of the names it actually
sometimes tells you something the Bible
is very deep and it's a amazing books
you'll never plumb the depths there's
always more amen thank you so if you
read if you read something right away
and you don't understand it it just keep
in mind that children don't understand
everything their parents say the first
day they meet they takes it come
sometimes years of listening before they
comprehend and sometimes you're 30 years
old before you realize what your parents
actually said when you were a kid oh now
that makes sense you know what I mean
yes thank you so much
all right Yvonne thanks for your call
did you know amazing fax has a free
Bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's words sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 four two one five 7,000
that's one eight four four two one five
7,000 all right talking next with Donna
calling from Oklahoma Donna you're on
the air with Bible answers live I am
here thank you Pastor Dan I appreciate
you answering question yes okay my
question is Adam and Eve walking in the
garden okay
they had just sent and they're still
walking in the garden now how could they
look upon God after they have sinned
well the way I understand it is have you
ever been in a dark room and then
someone turns on the light a bright
light and it just blinds you because it
hurts your eyes your eyes are adjusted
Adam and Eve had just sinned they had
been living in the light and the glory
of God their eyes were not yet adjusted
to the darkness that was kind of coming
upon the world and so shortly after
their sin when God came and met with
them I
they already felt convicted because they
ran from his presence and maybe got
veiled his glory with some cloud as he
did
the children of Israel when he spoke the
law we don't know but my opinion is that
they had been so recently living in the
presence of God their eyes had not grown
used to the dark yet and they could
still at least temporarily behold his
his presence okay I understand that
thank you very much all right thank you
appreciate your question we're gonna
talk next to Christie he was calling
from New Mexico is it Christine you're
on the air with Bible answers live so
faster my question is regarding
efficient chapter flora verse 11 I just
want to clarify if churches is required
or is it necessary for churches to have
a prophet that is alive at the present
time alright let me read about the gifts
of the Spirit he says here in Ephesians
4:11 and he gave some to be apostles
some prophets some evangelists some
pastors and teachers you know I think
technically we do have most of what you
see here the word prophet in in the
Bible did not always mean somebody that
was going around like Elijah or John the
Baptist with some profound message of
predicting the future the Bible talks
about Philip I mentioned earlier had
four daughters that did prophesy the
word prophesy sometimes meant to speak
in behalf of another and that simply
means to teach I think that it's just
saying that we still need people in the
church that have that gift of teaching I
do think we have that today now there's
a spiritual there's a special gift of
prophecy that God gives people I believe
in all the gifts of the Spirit and there
may be people who are prophets out in
the world and the church today I believe
that before God does anything
significant he usually sends a prophet
before the flood he sent Noah you know
before the children of Israel were
carried away to captivity he sent
Jeremiah and Isaiah before Jesus first
coming he sent John the Baptist before
the deliverance from Egypt he sent Moses
whenever there's something big about to
happen seems like God sends a prophet it
would make sense before the second
coming that the gifts of prophecy would
still be alive in the church you may not
have a
fossils in the sense people that walked
and talked with Jesus on earth but there
are still leaders in the church today
even the apostles replaced Judas Acts
chapter 1 when when he died by his own
hand all right thank you very much and
Christine we're gonna talk next to
Dwight Dwight you're on the air with
Bible answers live okay I got a quick
question not really a verse in mind but
kind of long the lines of spiritual
gifts and different things like how did
David know I know he knew he was
supposed to be king but how did he know
he wasn't making a mistake at that time
or wasn't God's plan for him to kill
Goliath or whatever and kind of like in
our lives whether it's business or where
you're gonna go to school or where you
need to live or whatever how do you know
that you're not going against God's will
in some situation where you're trying to
be holy and you think yeah I'm gonna
take this down God's behind me and then
you end up dead or something yeah yeah
well you mean with Goliath or with King
Saul because David refused to kill King
Saul when he had a chance to be king no
but I mean Goliath yeah but Goliath
because nothing to fight Goliath except
here's David out of nowhere he knew he
was going to be king one day he was told
at that before then but what if he was
making a mistake and it was God's plan
or something I'm trying to figure out
how to apply that to our life yeah I'll
tell you what I think on that is the
Holy Spirit came on David when he was
anointed he was filled with the spirit
the holy spirit guides you the Holy
Spirit also gives you boldness it kind
of gives you this holy audacity and when
when you read in Ephesians chapter 6
Paul says you know pray for boldness for
me in an axe chapter for the disciples
prayed that God would give them boldness
they would not be intimidated or afraid
that they'd have courage God told Joshua
have courage be very courageous I'm with
you David had that kind of courage he
had that confidence that someone needed
to step up in behalf of God and God was
bigger than Goliath and you know David
goes again
Goliath and he says you've got the sword
the spear the shield but I'm coming
against you in the name of the Lord so
he had this relationship with the Lord
that gave him a holy confidence and
that's yeah that's that's what I see in
the story is Holy Spirit gives you
boldness would you say that's similar
then to a lot of highly successful
people or you know this that's all
players or people who just have extremes
discipline and drive to do something
it's kind of similar mindset you know
they did a study it's interesting you
ask that back during World War two my
dad was a pilot in World War two he flew
in d-day and and he became a very
successful man he was a
multi-millionaire and a lot of the
people who became very successful they
interviewed a bunch of the pilots that
survived the war and they found out the
ones that survived some of the serious
fighting took calculated risks the ones
who were afraid of risk often did not
survive and it was just a very
interesting study and I wish I could
name it for you or put my finger on it
some of the very successful people they
do have a boldness and they take
calculated risks and you know could they
say greater risk greater reward you just
don't want to take the the wrong risk
and lose big too anyway I hope that
helps a little bit but that a good
question I appreciate that Dwight gonna
talk next - let me see here or Angelina
and Minnesota Angelina you're on the air
with Bible answers live are you there I
get the name right yep Angelina you
might have your phone muted Angelina
Minnesota Bible answer is live are you
there going once
Angelina Angelina you there going twice
okay now we're gonna talk to Leon Noah
in Texas am I saying that right yes hi
and your question um my question was in
the Garden of Eden before Adam and Eve
ate of the fruit of the tree were they
were they immortal and then they became
mortal after they ate the fruit
yeah good question well it talks about
eating from the tree of life you find
that in chapters 1 & 2 and well chapter
3 of course they were barred from the
Tree of Life
and God said he wouldn't let the meat of
the Tree of Life less they eat and live
forever he didn't want them to be
immortalized sinners so there evidently
was something in the tree that helped to
perpetuate life it at least kept your
cells from dying they didn't need to eat
it every day I mean out of an EVE lived
over 900 years it doesn't tell us Eve's
exact age but we're assuming that she
lived about the same age we're gonna eat
from the tree of life even in heaven we
still need it because we've got real
bodies but we'll live forever because we
get to eat from this tree all you got to
do is you know once every 200 years
there's no I don't know you we've got to
continue to eat from it it prevents the
cells from dying it adds something some
essence of life see even doctors don't
understand why you know they're
wondering if it's stem cells or what it
is something about when we're young are
we heal so quickly and the reason we end
up dying is because the cells lose the
ability to regenerate and something
starts to decay and they haven't put
their finger on it everybody's looking
for that Fountain of Youth but God says
we're not gonna get it until we get to
the new earth with that tree in the
Garden of Eden
so was there two trees was there a bad
one the one of the serpent was on and
then there was the Tree of Life
yes Bible says in the midst of the
garden there were two trees one was a
tree of life one was the tree of the
knowledge of good and evil that was the
one they were not supposed to eat from
God did not want them to experience the
evil so then they were immortal but when
they ate from that tree the bad one they
became mortal well yeah in the sense
that when they ate from that tree they
sinned and the penalty for sin is death
but it doesn't say the fruit made them
mortal no longer eating from the tree of
life made them mortal oh I see I think
it doesn't say anywhere they ate from
the tree of good and evil and they
started to die because the fruit did
something to him it does say they were
driven from the garden so they could no
longer eat from the tree of life hey
thank you so much lien Ella I appreciate
that and we're just didn't want to cut
you off or running out of time for this
broadcast friends if we didn't get your
call
God willing give us another chance and
we'll study his word together again next
week and keep in mind we are an entirely
faith-based ministry we'd appreciate so
much just go to amazing facts dot o-r-g
click donate keep us on the air for
yourself or someone else god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
[Music]
hello friends pastor Doug Batchelor here
with amazing facts when Susan's and
Michael's whirlwind relationship led to
a wedding they had no idea how hard
married life could be before they knew
it they were on the stormy path towards
divorce but that's when God led them to
an amazing fax broadcast and there they
saw the biblical view of marriage as
presented annoying Jesus
finally they understood what it meant to
love sacrificially like Christ and today
Susan and Michael are joyfully married
sharing what they learned with others
now you friend have an opportunity to
help someone today and to make an
eternal difference for more people like
Michael and Susan you're a simple
investment of faith and amazing facts
we'll keep growing and reaching more
people with God's life-changing word
would you prayerfully consider sending a
gift today
to help others know Christ and the
wonderful truth that you've learned and
it's easy to make a donation just visit
give dot amazing fax to RG or send your
gift to peel box
10:58 Roseville California 9 5 6 7 8 you
can also give us a call at eight seven
seven five zero six one seven five one
the number again eight seven seven five
zero six one seven five one thank you
for tuning in to Bible answers live and
don't forget to share with others the
amazing Bible facts you have learned
here today written by the hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
[Music]
yet pastor Doug bachelors 12 part sermon
series on the 10 commandments by calling
805 3 8 72 75 or visit AF bookstore calm
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF AG 0 RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]